[Musique]
joyeuses fêtes de noël
vous êtes monsieur je sais ce que je
dois faire je vais leur volley noël tout
va disparaître
tu me lis arrivé voici
cookie il est notre pire ennemi
non non nous devons résister je vous
balance le traîneau depuis le toit
compris c'est parti
c'est la neige la plus bruyants que j'ai
entendu de toute ma vie pour devenir le
père noël je doit l'étudier et entrer
dans la peau du personnage
[Musique]
aller en piste
bien
tout ça c'est des transports première
classe
o o
non
[Musique]
aux escales originaux vrai
ça va
max tu as mérité une promotion tu
tiendras montré non c'est que oui qu'est
ce que max
le gris ni max tu connais le règlement
toi tu dors dans ton lit et je dors dans
mon c'est toi qui lui a appris à faire
les yeux de chatons
bon d'accord